after seven seasons one half of mom's
mother-daughter duo will have to face
what life throws at them
alone in early september 2020 it was
announced that anna ferris who has
starred in the highly rated tv comedy
since it debuted in 2013
wouldn't be returning for the series
eighth season that meant
her appearance on mom's april 16th
episode big sad eyes and a wrinkled hot
dog
would be her last why am i here
oh you're just in a little slump you'll
get out of it the episode was season 7's
20th
an unexpectedly final episode after
filming was cut
short due to the industry-wide
production shutdowns caused by covet 19.
at the time ferris's departure was
announced warner brothers tv cbs and
chuck laurie productions said in a
statement
from the inception of mom anna was the
first and only choice for the role of
christy
we are so proud of the stories that we
have been able to tell during anna's
seven years with us
we wish anna all the best and we thank
her for her beautiful portrayal
ferris's role as recovering addict and
single mom kristy plunkett
won't be recast meaning her exit leaves
her co-star alison janney who plays
christy's mother bonnie as the show's
sole lead in recent years however the
series about a formerly estranged mother
and daughter attempting to keep the
relationship and their lives together
while staying sober
has become more of an ensemble with
supporting cast members mimi kennedy
jamie presley beth hall william fichner
and kristen johnston
all getting their roles expanded thr
reported that ferris's departure hasn't
caused any major impact in the writers
room for the series going into season 8.
according to deadline the actress's exit
was finalized early during the show's
hiatus meaning the writers had already
planned to craft the season without
christy
while mom's creative team may have been
prepared for ferris to go
the news has left many fans wondering
why she decided to leave so suddenly
especially amid such a successful run
the announcement was particularly
shocking considering she was in the
middle of a two-year contract
which she signed in the spring of 2019
following extensive negotiations
jani inked the very same deal which
would ensure the two would stay on the
comedy through season 8.
thr noted in september 2020 that despite
the
impact of the production shutdown in the
show's 7th and 8th seasons
sources close to the production
confirmed that covet 19 concerns weren't
behind
ferris's decision to leave the show in a
statement the actress made clear that
the timing of her departure was
instead more about a personal career
move saying
the past seven years on mom have been
some of the most fulfilling and
rewarding of my career
i'm so thankful to chuck the writers and
my amazing cast mates for creating a
truly wonderful work experience
while my journey is christy has come to
an end allowing me to pursue other
opportunities
i'll be watching next season and rooting
for my tv family
at the time news of ferris's exit went
public multiple
outlets reported that her departure
would be addressed on the series when it
returned for season eight
sure enough the mom's season 8 premiere
which aired thursday november 5th
did just that christy's season 7 arc
primarily focused on continuing her
journey in law school
alongside a series of romantic mishaps
and misadventures
and the start of season eight sees
bonnie driving home after dropping
christy off at the airport
christy's headed to georgetown law
school which she got accepted to on a
full scholarship
every mom dreams of the day when they
drop their 42 year old daughter off at
the airport to go to school
and i did it all by myself janie shared
with cnn that in wrapping up christy's
story the series offers a positive
message about recovery
saying we talked about how sometimes in
recovery your life can get bigger than
you ever thought possible
and i think that's what happens for
christy fellow mom star jaime presley
who plays recovering alcoholic jill
kendall on the show
agreed saying it's really important to
showrunner gemma baker to portray a
character
that got sober and stayed sober not
somebody that fell apart and had to
start all over again
i think that was really important moving
forward
mom will focus on bonnie's feelings of
loneliness and empty nest syndrome and
place emphasis on the narrative arcs of
other characters
overall though mom fans won't have much
to worry about without ferris in tow
as tami actress kirsten johnston said it
doesn't feel that different
i mean obviously i miss anna but it's
still just mom
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you